cette généralistes un pour quatre mille
cinq cent cinquante habitants trappe et
en zone d'intervention prioritaire
ce médecin généraliste est arrivé en
mars dans une maison de santé
que cherchait une installation en groupe
parce que j'avais travaillé souvent en
cuir allons médecins isolés
j'avais fait beaucoup de campagnes et au
bout d'un moment bah voilà j'avais
voulu m'installer à plusieurs pour des
raisons de
proactivité on va dire du système de
santé d'être à plusieurs ça nous permet
quand même de discuter sur les cas
difficiles à l'origine du projet ce
jeune médecin déjà praticiens sur la
ville depuis 2014
il a choisi de s'installer durablement
un projet à plus d'un million d'euros
on a eu des réponses positives au niveau
de la région et au niveau de la rsr ps
qui nous ont permis en subventionnant
une partie de l'investissement du coup
d'agrandir notre surface de cabinet
médical est d'accueillir de nouveaux
professionnels de santé des appuis
techniques municipaux et des subventions
financières à hauteur notamment de
250000 euros
du côté de l' agence régionale de santé
et de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé
d'abord faciliter l'immobilier puisque
l'immobilier est un coût important
en ile de france et donc dans le budget
économique d'un cabinet médical qui est
quand même une petite entreprise à magny
les hameaux c'est un pôle santé qui
s'est créée à l'été 2010 8 plus de
120000 euros de travaux dans l'ancien
pmi pour accueillir les patients dans le
quartier du buisson il n'y a plus de
généralistes depuis une quinzaine
d'années en centre ville il ya quatre
médecins ça ça doit faire cinq
équivalents temps pleins de médecins
mais dans un rayon de 200 mètres chacun
donc dans le quartier de l'hôtel de
ville
par contre ici où il y à la moitié de la
population environ 4500 habitants
il n'y a aucun generali en contact avec
la rs depuis deux ans la ville a trouvé
une solution
des consultations avancées d'un médecin
urgentiste de l'hôpital privé de trappes
il consulte chaque mercredi depuis le
mois d'octobre c'est pas la même façon
de travailler les mêmes moyens
techniques mais c était un partenariat
et j'ai trouvé que c'était intéressant
de pouvoir faire un poste avancé de
l'hôpital et pouvoir dépanner les gens
et pouvant les accueillir dans une
structure en avant d'hôpital s'il ya pas
besoin du plateau technique une relation
ville-hôpital aussi envisagé à plaisir
la ville actuellement en discussion avec
la rs et le département s'associe avec
l' hôpital gérontologique et médico
social nous avons un terrain qui est
vraiment à l'entrée de cet hôpital qui
serait tout à fait le terrain adéquat
pour
pouvoir faire cette maison médicale un
médecin pour déjà porté le projet et
ensuite je pense que avec toute
l'énergie que l'on met en place
actuellement on sent des frémissements
il y a des médecins il ya des
gynécologues par exemple qui se sont
rapprochés de nous on a des infirmières
qui se rapprochent de nous parce qu'il
faut aussi du paramédical
on a décliné certains généralistes
aujourd'hui la maison pourrait voir le
jour d'ici deux trois ans actuellement
la ville compte huit généralistes pour
près de trente deux mille habitants